est ce que vous avez l'habitude vous
prendre des râteaux tu m'emmerdes du
tout cette séquence je vais râteau je te
jure cas là ça va paraître prétentieux
aussi mais se croient que ça ne m'est
jamais arrivé quel est votre technique
de drague j'en ai pas tellement mon show
les gens viennent vers moi et dans mes
yeux envoyé pas vous en voyez pas un ami
parfois dire mathieu de leurs bouts ou
tard terry par jean louis et magnolia
les vrais géants fête en fait je vais
vous expliquer je dis la vérité je ne
vois rien de loin ouais bon du coup
c'est un peu flou donc j'avais un pote
qui connaît mes goûts qui misait nan nan
nan lui c'est ton goût donc il y allait
alors je ferai pas de verre il allait
chercher un autre pas terrain il
l'oranais je voyais de près je voyais
qu'effectivement c'était à mon goût et
puis ensuite bon bah c'est une angoisse
le charme fait est fait alors j'ai tout
donné des indices si vous dit des
soirées du crazy for men bataclan
olalala
que je payais pas les verts c'est par là
bas ne faisait pas là que
je vous lis chirurgie esthétique et
coupe au bol
si je vous dis christophe alias monsieur
astuces
je pense que cette vidéo va vous
rafraîchir la maison à regarder
il m'a draguée d'ailleurs une fois
matthieu delormeau oui crazy bord au
bataclan alors il ya une technique de
drague très surprenant d'envoi reims aux
amis celui ci vient me voir et me dit
j'ai quelqu'un de présenter genre tu
sais le prince quand on voit son laquais
et chercher le pas du midi quoi du soir
je vais voir je fais bonjour bonjour je
sortis quand même
une petite gêne quand même que je le
reconnais ce pas ça leur fait mal parce
qu'il m'a même pas payer un verre alors
qu'on a discuté pendant 15 minutes et au
dernier moment où mon fatidique il me
dit alors est-ce que tu rentres avec
nous ce soir d'accord alors j'ai dit ben
coudon voilà vous l'avez mis en avant
oui
tu es ce que tu me connais je n'ai
jamais vu ce garçon en plein jour de ma
vie quoi t'attendre tout ce que
je n'ai jamais vu ce gars est non
non je n'ai jamais vu ce garçon de ma
vie alors mythe au total attention tu
sais que le nombre de mito qui se vante
d'avoir couché avec moi ça c'est vrai
une fois dans une boîte j'en ai vu un
qui s'était vanté jeudi devait y avoir
de tes potes tu as couché avec moi dans
ses potes il était tout rouge il l'avait
jamais vue explique comprendre qu'on
s'en vantent les 10 km et du coup dit
mary dans ma life mais l'état doit tuer
la louer alors non mathieu oui pourtant
ce qu'il dit correspond à votre tqm ces
personnes il raconte que vous lui avez
pas payer le vert donc on vous reconnaît
cette fois lorsque vous effectivement
cessé ces jeunes gens dans les boîtes de
balles qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie
j'ai su animateur de télé désolé je
regarde pas la télé bon très bien au bac
je confie mon on papote que vous de 5,6
vers tu m'as fait marrer
mais je n'ai jamais vu ce garçon
sait pas du tout ce n'est pas du tout
mais il est beaucoup trop jeune je je je
je je ne sais même pas qui c'était pour
une interview mais c'est monsieur il est
suivi par 1,2 million de personnes 1 2
million de mercis astuces de quoi chez
asus s est beaucoup plus
astucieux astuces oui messieurs dames
annoncer n'importe quoi la télé tu es
monsieur astuces et ben vous savez quand
je suis monsieur merguez je faire john
alors monsieur bergasse c'est moi non
monsieur tu sais pas s'il vous plaît ou
pas mais enfin écoutez je d'abord je
n'ai pas à juger les physiques mais ce
n'est pas du tout mon genre et bah
écoutez monsieur astuce est un mytho
c'est pour vous dire la vérité puisqu'il
est là ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'être là c'est un gars très bas
coût du fils de montiel
alors vous la connaissez c'est vrai par
ailleurs cinq ans et c'est vrai ça
correspond au moment c'est vrai on se
marie cette nature kressmann en taclant
et en plus qui décrit s'est
présentée c'est un pote à lui qu'est
venu oui aurait t'il à une méthode très
particulière c'est qu'ils envoient
inspire un homme de main alors il
prétend qu'un ami prétend qu'il a des
problèmes de vue mais là tu me vois très
bien je suis sûr et d'autres imid qu'il
envoie quelqu'un pourra
pour que je puisse époque il se présente
lui-même enfin c'est très particulier
mais c'est le genre voyez quelqu'un
était venu oui mais je savais pas que
j'allais voir on m'a dit je vais te
présenter un producteur n'ont intéressé
monsieur est banal
5 km de louga quelqu'un lui dit ya
quelqu'un qui veut te voir ci-bas
oui c'est vrai que l'état voilà 6 mois 1
mais par contre dans ce qui m'a dit non
au visage de monsieur ce qui m'a un
petit peu éclairé s'il n'a pas payé un
verre alors qu'on était à trois mètres
du bar on a parlé pendant 20 minutes il
m'a proposé de rentrer avec son ami chez
lui non oui et pas un verre rien ils
m'aiment pas
[Applaudissements]
abordable à la maison qu'on coupe un peu
ce que tu me reconnais ou pas alors je
vous pourrez vous mettre tout nu
peut-être
comme ça déjà à l'époque non non non
c'est pas ça bah oui celui-là sur
l'esthétique du fil c'est pour ça que
j'ai peut-être pas reconnue mais alors
annette otto bock
on a une photo de moi n'est pas croyable
ouais mais c'est ah bah oui c'est sûr
c'est sur
le gars sait pas il avait
65 ans vous l'avez proche mais c'était
pas mal c'est en guinguette ou quoi non
mais le gâteau
c'est mathieu jaton style sans savoir si
cet avantage ou prêt oui alors d'abord
envoyé
[Rires]
[Musique]
chris quel âge avez vous trente ans donc
vous avez la 62e
vous avez quel âge à l'époque bassavé 25
53 25 je vous ai dit que c'était à 5 ans
et à 50 m en donne à la mi-temps la
wimax et on perd c'est pas clair ton
histoire d'apprendre à déchiffrer des
rues dit que c'était vers 22-23 cents à
nous allier à ces accords il ya cinq ans
elle chante beaucoup de choses parce
qu'il ya cinq ans j'étais en couple
avec moi tu as toujours été en couple
alors j'ai pas de budget pas du tout
toujours été en couple souvent le nom
mais vous vous reçoit c'est pas parce
que vous conduisez une voiture vous en
loup et pas une autre et ces promesses
de terminer en voiture
les 11e en voiture non tu n'as pas
précisé les modalités mais tu m'a
simplement dit de si on pouvait rentrer
ensemble avec ton ami et qu'est ce que
tu as dit j'ai dit non bon allez vous
faire [ __ ] parce qu'en fait j'avais
fait genre que je te connaissais pas
parce qu'en fait c'était
bien et du coup j'ai fait genre que il
me dit mais qu'est ce que tu fais dans
la vie où je suis moi je fais ça et lui
et moi je lui demande qu'est ce que tu
fais dans la vie ce qu'il est un peu
dérangée salle un peu trouble et j'ai vu
dans les yeux ça va tourmenté et
documents et bruno jeudy banon et tu as
dis je travaille dans la télé je dis ok
mais c'est ça je pense que tu quittes a
pas plus et je te reconnaissent pas au
poids du tout
c'est
en pleine ville
barcelone c'est mathieu
je connais moi comme j'ai fait ce genre
que j'avais parcouru où j'ai beaucoup
moins on fait tout ça c'est normal c'est
pas vrai j'ai la patate et non mais
alors que je porte si tu crois qu'au
choix du parti c'était une plaisanterie
non il est
coutume avait vu tu avais vu mes muscles
sens et c'est ça qui taperait gauche
martin oui oui les couches sportif
oui il s'entraîne avec des bols
mais vous avez vu un délai de mathieu ou
par un détail anatomique qua non dieu
merci non je n'ai pas déraper
mieux peut-être parce que ça me
ressemble je t'ai proposé de partager un
beurre parce que je suis con en
absolutions
voiturage alors si comme le prénom cri
comme est dommage qu il faut baiser
s'il vous plaît non mais je suis content
de le revoir oui je ne t'ai jamais vide
mais pas de même cette émotion ce qui se
passe c'est rémy j'adore mais te dire ça
mais combien moi j'adore le trémolo dans
la voix elle n'arrive pas à accepter ce
bien compris en fait il est rentré avec
moi parce que tu je me la péter parce
que j'étais animateur argueil mais tu en
avais envie pas du tout non je te
plaisait pas
non c'est vrai que tu es beau garçon va
pas se mentir alors mais c'est d'être la
méthode de rentrer à trois avec un étai
vallègue amis me présente à toi je
trouve ça un peu bizarre entre 3 et
conduisait mathieu vous êtes content
d'être là j'adore ça ouais je suis
content de le revoir alors avant savard
est si précaire vous avez par album non
[Rires]
moi je propose qu on recrée non écrite
mais non
riesch est ce que vous voulez vous
mettre là c'est la piste oui on va dire
que vous êtes en train de danser oui non
je te vois tu rentres dans sa cible ou
alors
c'est moi c'est mieux mais bon le bateau
alors a devant lui c'est plus dangereux
non oui il avait deux doigts ça doit
vous dansez et on va voir si mathieu way
a envie de venir partager une bombe
les
[Applaudissements]
la dernière fois
alors j'ai battu mathieu en ce temps là
oui j'ai eu des petits soucis à la
maison à la raison ou c'est lui à la
mienne je n'ai pas ça quand je tenais
qui tue pas toi avec un et qui personne
avec qui je partage ma vie nathan s est
pas une petite danse avec bobonne
thé dansant qui paraît si tu as quelque
ou alors
je vais préciser où il partage ma vie là
partagé bien cinq ans à aa certains qui
se souviennent non alors moi me non
échus sanary la
maladie bien sûr à 8,7 aller draguer je
vais te dire moi franchement pas
vraiment ce qu'on mettait la musique de
ballet non non tu me fous
alors non la tête choix mais quoi enfin
coiffer la scène non non la la la alors
on laisse présent puisque tu voulais pas
envie de venir non non mais bon je suis
sûr qu'on puisse voir comment en
coulisses tu vas marié non mais tu
arrêtes avec ça mais il ya cinq ans
servait à 5 ans j'étais fou où j'étais
un chien fou je suis animateur je suis
posée la ménagère là
à
quoi s'est juré dr mafia qu'un charlatan
lave et un jour c'est quoi passer un
mois que tu n'es pas moi t'as pas vu lui
lécher le bol oh non
[Applaudissements]
si urgent qui le regardent
oui c'est l'hôtesse suite à bangui dans
celle ci va pas je veux qu'il y des
femmes accorsi peut-être que tu regardes
et il dit peut-être mais voilà je devais
être très calmes n'aurait pas nouvelle
on serait déjà je vais très cash ce
garçon oui je sais ça s'écrit
jean kunz avait vu autant perturber ah
oui non oui l'amour l'amour est il a
quelque chose tu n' était dégoûté les
routes et des routes et c'est une
mascarade l'a vu gagner la paupière
supérieure libre ah oui et pas qu'adria
par axa qui vibre garde fous droite
les psys ont maintenant tu es toi tu
irais voit sa pomme d'adam simple tuer
tuer tuer tuer tous si tu dois certes
non je dois certainement beaucoup de
succès en boîte de nuit oui je te
souhaite utiliser un très beau gay ouais
mais maintenant si reebok a beau car il
ya des gays voici maintenant vraiment tu
veux vivre l'amour avec un reggae il
faut que tu ailles tarkan non
là non
t'nb
cheikh omar el casal du suroît de l'anus
nord
non mais
c'est passé il aurait pas de mal le
président m'a dit non mais tu connais
bien sexuellement benjamin non pas du
tout
aujourd'hui je reconnais rld presse
alors vous danser ensemble s'il a pris
des bouteilles d'air et serrières
ensemble un récent avec lui tu pourras
faire un petit bol de saucisses cocktail
crise moi je voudrais bien tu sais que
tu jeu j'ai eu un mois moi en tout cas
j'ai eu un coup de coeur pour lui
alors professionnels moi je suis comme
ça tous les geôles du sujet ça non non
non non non j'ai pas le jeu du je te
bouffe ferai pas le coup
non crise et ben ouais comme j'ai eu un
coup de coeur c'est vrai mais crise très
sympathique pas mal du tout oui à un
vraiment à noter qu'il a dit que j'ai
été très gentil très courtois